[Musique]
zerbage signifie en créole remède
pouvoir se soigner par les plantes est
une tradition à la Réunion à savoir
souvent transmis de génération en
génération et qui perdure avec la
connaissance de nos tisaneurs
aujourd'hui partons à la découverte du
zambaville cette plante endémique de la
Réunion et de l'île Maurice pousse entre
1000 et 2000 m d'altitude ces tiges sont
pourvu de petites feuilles d'enté avec à
leur extrémité des fleurs de couleur
jaune et
blanche là c'est un joli petit plan de
zabaville m en terre depuis 3 ans 4 ans
à peu près et là 3 ans 4 ans ouais c'est
la première fois qu'il vient pour
tailler là donc petite taille
assez assez costaud assez sévère pour au
moins quand il passe la saison cyclone
là il a pas trop de branch pour casser
le aville il pousse dans les EAU c'est
une plante endémique de la Réunion et
une des tisarnes les plus utilisé
dans tisanes réunionnais dans Baville
avec le fleurs jaune comme petit arbuste
qui là c'est qu'on trouve dans B ville
normalement trouve
jaune ce
serait beaucoup de ch à dire sur en
Baville parce que un petit souvenir
d'enfance moi Mo devais avoir 8 ans 9
ans la gale t s V temps longtemps dans
les années 60 et un vieux bonhomme a eu
la case avec un petit BR Baville un
petit peu fum terre et un petit peu la
chaud au bout de 3 jours moi puis la
gale c'était très très très dur pour
moive ma petite sœur nous était dans le
lit depuis une semaine à s de la gale
desmanger bon plus plus plus desmangison
plus plus plus et incroyable ça la
marque à moins parce que le monsieur à
peine sil connaî lire tu connais il tu
connais pas lire tu connais pas écrire à
peine si tu g causé et mon impression
est jusqu'à aujourd'hui ce monsieurl
connu et reconnu dans toute la toute
l'Ouest monsieur émil Lespart c'est un
grand bonhomme parce que il connaissait
la forêt comme çaain voilà zambaville
est très utilisé aussi dans toutes les
tisanes que soit diabète que ce soit
cholestérol que ce soit
bouestomacestomac zamb ville est très
utilisé pour les problème de peau aussi
donc que ce soit en interne ou en
externe lesambas ville est partout dans
la tisane réonnaise et presque part pas
vraiment pas partout mais parque partout
dans les
tisanes interne et
externe une petite idée les problème de
peau eczéma des bains avec associé avec
d'autres plantes les personnes voi
l'ffet au bout
de peu de temps une semaine de semaines
3 semaines si la personne il fait
attention aussi à ce que il m dedans ce
qu'il
mangeamb peut être un très bon
complément complément pour finir avec
des problèmes de de peau coute tout est
bon dans un B ville moi personnellement
quand qu'on a une branche dans B ville
comme ça que ce soit le bois là que nous
voit le petit bois le petit es que soit
les feuilles les fleurs là c'est
vraiment juste à point parce que c'est
bon moment là petite fleur comme ça
couper ça finement et faire sa
préparation tout est bon làdedans moi
jamais utilisé la racine mais la racine
do être bonne pour quelque chose mais en
général on pas tuer le pied on va
tailler de façon que ça repousse ça va
reboisonner d'ici quel
temps
[Musique]
bon trè préparation décotion là nous va
prendre l'eau froide qu'elle est là nous
ver dans la
Bouloire et dans cette Bouloire en même
temps nous va mettre des plantes une
décooction de zambaville par exemple
zambaville et fume terre un zambaville
et pocpc là
pour laver là nous fait un petit peu de
plante comme ça pour à peu près 1 L dem
1 L 1 L de un bon l demi là c'est dit
bien décoction pour le bain 1 L 1 L dei
on peut rajouter un peu de pocp dedans
regarde bien le POC POC c'est POC POC
c'est POC POC hein marma qui connait pas
pocpoc al la app pocpoc il trouve ça
dans carocorne mais pas dans n'importe
quelle carocorne parce que un poisson
pareil pour toute plante donc veuillez
bien à ne pas ramasser n'importe où le
pocpoc très bon pour le psoriasis très
bon pour les problèmes de peau là nous
fait une petite préparation nous peut
rajouter là d'autres plantes mais là
c'est pour montrer comment nous fait une
décoction donc nous la verse de l'eau
nous la verse de l'eau dedans l'eau est
froide nous metett les PL
dedans
nous recouffre la casserole le le
bouloir normalement ça se fait dans une
grande marmite dans une grande casserole
nous fait ça pour 5 10 L là c'est
démonstration nous chauffe nous laisse
de l'eau bouillir la décocction dans 5 7
minutes 10 minutes mais
bon c'est vrai qu'avant plein d' Baville
un peu partout dans les EAU il commence
Devi r comment il est arrivé ici ce
chemin là dans 35 ans avit des piedsemb
ville tout le long du chemin la route du
ma zambille sur le chemin là il peut
compter sur Do d'une main combien de PE
zambaville reste donc comme c'est c'est
une plante un petit Arbus très connu
très utilisé nous a intérêt à PL c'est
ce que est en train de fait on plé cette
année une centaine de pieds mais encore
le temps même plus à planter je pense
que dans tous les hauts de l'ouest là
laavenir des haut il peut passer paremb
ville les flun déjà pour commencer si
Domon il comprend que l'avenir est
là-dedans l'avenir est dans les tisanes
ça est sûr et certain que dans 10 15 20
ans nous va reparler les haut de l'Î
pourrait retrouver notre valorisation à
côté d'un peu de géranium ou d'autres
petites cultures associé le zambasille
le Flagon pl
planter des arbres médicinales zamb
ville Gouill marron et cetera et
ceteraer de la place et puis des arbres
mlifères aussi bon miel bon Miel Vert là
c'est dans les haau qui n fait ça voilà
ce que pourrait dire sur ville a
beaucoup de faire pour apprendre encore
sur les ville beaucoup deffire pour di
sur zamb ville à finir avec avec les
médicaments zambille peut
[Musique]
aider